I'm starting to get nauseous I'm
starting to feel lost I forget what time
you got here
that's just set up camp here I know that
it is Swedish I imagine it's gotta be
pretty big there's one thing I was
raised to do it's to hunt a good deal so
if the deals are good I'm gonna love it
it's supposed to be sort of a circus and
I really enjoy shopping and circuses so
it looks like a 90s roller coaster
here's a challenge find the cheapest
desk the best couch and pasta and
everything that makes pasta look at
their tasteful use of crates this is
what happens when pac-man dies
your skin uppity make him into these oh
I'm trapped in an Ikea shower
this chair can withstand even the
slowest walking so we've lost Katie in
the depths of Ikea and that would be
anywhere we're gonna have to backtrack
to find her bed number one bed number
two bed number three this is just some
birds this is getting like we can haggle
wipsy mite in hours we don't know how
long it's been I just wanna like spend
money now when I started I was very
excited cuz I love shopping we were like
little ants finding our way through the
ant tunnel and then immediately when we
got upstairs I found stylus finish this
is step one on my pasta journey because
I always use my cell spinner as my
screener
thanks for laid out very cute but then
you get a couple rooms deep and you
realize that you're just in this
apartment that goes on forever and
eventually we found the mat we realized
when we got to this map this place was
[ __ ] huge you keep going along a path
but it's not really clear where it's
going and like the deeper you go the
creepier it got with like people's
clothes being there joke's on you
taking these there were probably more
comfortable couches than the one I
picked but I liked how mine look this is
the couch I picked the arcsine because I
love the orange color of it and the name
reminds me of Steve Urkel's girlfriend
the next one was the cheapest desk which
I think I found because I found a laptop
table $40 $40
we finally reached the middle of the
store we were exhausted we thought this
must be the end of the store is actually
only the halfway point but this was
where they had the famous IKEA food
which to their credit that food is
really cheap and so then we had to make
it out through another half of the store
which then became tiny little plates and
candles and lamps and stuff
wait now grab a card I won't have to
sleep on that couch anymore where are we
only now the part where you guys see you
know that was initially confusing
because I started to look for pasta
stuff right away and it was sort of
scattered throughout the different
kitchens
there's no bowls we're gonna have to
journey to the new location for bowls
all of a sudden we got into this
marketplace and now there it all is
pasta Markel's
supports strainer pot nailed it the
marketplace was a weird purgatory but
this was the area where I started
getting pretty impressed with the prices
got 3 bucks
I got a lay up for you and so after you
make it through all the store parts then
you go to the warehouse it was like a
Home Depot but there was nobody there to
help you we have to build them and set
up a display for a whole new set of
customer oh wait do we get to use the
we working they had these computers
where you look up a numbering system to
find the thing that you're looking for X
towards X or find it the numbering
system has nothing to do with the order
that they're actually placed in along
the wall so then I just had to look for
the name and Katie made fun of me for
even trying to use the number system
what can I say I went in what for my
couch found it I won I would say IKEA
actually exceeded my expectations
because I didn't think it would be so
big
the idea of um back now is terrible I
don't wanna go back but those prices
were so low I bought a memory foam
pillow for 13 bucks I would probably go
back it was an emotional roller coaster
I think people say like if you want a
relationship to last you should travel
together but I think what they mean to
say is if you want a relationship to
last you should travel to Ikea together
restrooms may be located near the
restroom but this toilets right here
d'artagnan when you go to the bathroom
what does anyone do in the bathroom its
private business